The Wizard of Oz is one of my favorite
movies of all time and terrified me it
thrilled me just like every other kid in
America who sat on TV this is a story of
the wizard in The Wizard of Oz and how
he got to the magical land of Oz and who
he was and the people he met and how he
became the wizard he tried to tell the
story from a real straightforward way of
James Franco's character the wizard was
what he wanted the sins that he was
guilty of his character flaws and how
once he was swept oz how he got a second
chance and sometimes failed but usually
succeeded in becoming a better person
becoming more a selfless person
it's a 3d picture so visually I'm really
trying to make use of the extra
dimension that it offers to create
fantastical place about the rainbow that
can hold all these magical and marvelous
things there's a lot to the world of Oz
tremendous amount of the land of Oz
there is Glinda's kingdom which is an
entire universe onto itself and yes that
has his own colors and its own styles
that's I believe our production designer
did that in a French Nouveau and he's
got a more of a pastel thing going on
there where is in the Land of Oz it's
much more cosmopolitan the harder edge
much more light and shadow there are
many worlds in odds there's there's a
dark forest which is all much sharper
angles and high contrast I don't have
one look for the movie this there's so
many different asks so many of the
worlds within the Land of Oz that each
of them has their own looks it's a
family film it's different than the
films I've made before it's not a horror
film like I've made a lot of nor is it
an action picture I just loved the
script so much i loved the story and the
character I was moved by it emotionally
I thought it was sweet and funny and I
thought this is an entertainment movie
I'd really like to see and when I feel
that that's when I know it's right for
me to direct it's really a very
different film that I've ever had
anything to do it I feel more like a
conductor on this of great artists that
I've assembled around me to pull off a
very complex musical piece
you